hier à cannes le 15 mai c'est de la
danse de la politique d'auteur mais pas
cueillir à cannes c'est des coupes au
bol des femmes sur le tapis donc mais un
peu moins dans le jury la vie est belle
le 15 mai 76 pour jim kelly fred astaire
mais aussi cary grant est incertain
johnny ouest muller qui ne ressemble
plus à tarzan à cannes sur le tarmac
il débarque pour présenter hollywood
hollywood et répété que non les comédies
musicales et eux avec n'appartiennent
pas qu'au passé
je suis sûr que les français aiment
beaucoup la danse la musique les
chansons c'est un film des joies
comprenait la preuve en dansant et en
2013 au 15 mai 2013 c'est l'équipe de
gatsby le magnifique
carey mulligan péter maguire mais aussi
leonardo dicaprio qui débarque pour
esquisser quelques pas sur la croisette
gaspille les années phone plus une année
passée à chanter pardon à danser sous la
pluie car le 15 mai 98 à cannes on
apprenait qu'une voix s'éteignait frank
sinatra the voice hier à cannes ce n'est
pas que des marches un tapis des écrans
géants lire à cannes c'est aussi des
tribunes assez libre et des conférences
de presse qui le sont aussi
vous êtes lassé du film ce que vous
voulez je crois que vous avez de 15 à 75
et michelangelo antonioni
mais c'est aussi spike lee en 2018 et
avec l'histoire des états unis united
center
on se doute prendre des jeunes pour le
15 mai hier à cannes comme aujourd'hui
c'est des grands écrans et des grands
écarts c'est des femmes toutes les
femmes
l'ère de la starlette a disparu le 15
mai 76 c'est sylvia kristel au bord
d'une piscine
une combinaison nominations entre
l'amusement et l'importante en 92 c'est
victoria abril dans une robe plus pedro
almodovar en 88 c'est la cicciolina -
une robe sur le tapis rouge après le
chic
le choc de la cicciolina le 15 mai 76
il y a beaucoup de femmes il y en a
beaucoup sur la plage la croisette sur
les marches mais ce 15 mai 76 dans le
jury du festival de cannes
il n'y a qu'une femme est ce que vous
pensez que qu'il est très bon qu'il n'y
ait qu'une seule femme dans un jury
semblables il faudrait peut-être khan et
plusieurs ne pensez pas que c'est un
petit peu
[Musique]
hier à cannes c'est aujourd'hui enfin
jusqu'ici